this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host today flying
solo once again
the number to call triple eight eight
two five five two two five i would love
to help you take the right next step
with your life and your money maybe
you're at a crossroads you need some
confirmation some affirmation you think
you know what to do you just need a
random guy to tell you it's the right
thing or you might need me to talk you
off a ledge if you're about to cash out
your 401k because you're scared the sky
is falling happy to do either today on
the ramsay show triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the number to
call we're here for you
america ann uh is on the line but so is
nicholas so let's go to him first he's
in harrisonburg virginia nicholas
welcome to the show
hi it's pleasure to be here did i throw
you off there i was trying to just give
you a little curveball
no no no
how can i help today
um so just want to start off by saying
i'm a huge fan of the show and i'm a
huge fan of these work um i'm a 23 year
old guy looking to um you know start my
future right and um
i have just
a couple little um pickles i was hoping
you could help me out
i'm i specialize in brine cucumbers how
can i help with that what's going on
so
the first problem is uh
unfortunately two months ago i was in a
car accident and i totaled my car and
the the insurance company um gave me 3
200
and
you know thankfully nobody was hurt
however
however
i'm kind of in dire streets at the
moment um
luckily
my family has a
kind of a a project car that i've been
driving around but it's got about 175
000 miles on it it's thrown check engine
lights like crazy we've already put you
know
as a family we've already put over six
to seven thousand dollars into it um and
it's kind of it it's not a good thing to
be driving around it's um it's from 2004
um it's an old jedi so
um
i need a new car that's the first thing
the second thing is um
i'm moving out to roanoke this summer
and my rent is
going up from five hundred and four
dollars a month um to 960 dollars a
month and
my yearly income is 42 000
dollars
with uh
five thousand dollars in guaranteed
bonuses and then a twenty five hundred
dollar move expected so it all evens out
to about forty nine thousand five
hundred dollars okay and um i just
i just picked up a second job as well
i'm working home at home depot i'm
doing nights um because i kind of want
to set up another buffer for myself so
um
you know that'll bring my yearly income
up to about maybe fifty two thousand to
fifty five thousand good okay that's
awesome so how can i help today yeah
well um i've got twenty thousand dollars
um in student loan debt and
i really want to attack that
as soon as possible because i don't like
being in debt
and
you know i have a grace period until
august 31st and um i was just wondering
if you could help me lay out my
priorities because obviously i need a
new car
but the car market is really not awesome
right now and
you know i
there's different schools of thought you
know some people saying i should finance
i don't want to finance because i don't
want to take on more debt
i think uh
i you know i i think i could probably
get something reasonable for around um
six or seven grand i'm correct
with
with my with my rent going up um you
know
um
now that it's 960 dollars a month and
that's utility isn't everything oh good
okay i feel a lot better then
yeah so um so how much debt do you have
total you got 20k in student loans how
much other debt
that's it okay good and how much money
do you have in the bank
um about 10 500. this is fantastic news
okay
and that includes that 3200 check you
got from the insurance company
that does okay so if i'm you i'm
filtering this through a very simple
process
called the baby steps and so your step
one is a thousand dollar emergency fund
which good news is you have that already
in the bank
and then on top of that i'm gonna go get
a car asap that's like you said probably
a six seven thousand dollar car on this
market better than what you're driving
now
nothing fancy
but your goal is to
find a decent deal in today's market
which is not impossible don't let people
scare you off and say well the car
market's impossible yes it's not a great
time to buy cars but it's not a terrible
time to buy a six thousand dollar car
it's gonna be high mileage i would go
with a honda or a toyota uh that would
be my pick for you
for reliability
and then beyond that you probably will
have what another two thousand dollars
left over
yes okay and so then i would begin the
debt snowball where you list your debts
smallest to largest so you have your
student loans is it one student loan or
multiple
um it's multiple okay so list amount
smallest to largest ignore the interest
rate because this is all about behavior
and progress right now and start
attacking that little one with a
vengeance with your side job with all of
your income and i want you to be on an
every dollar budget a zero-based budget
where your income minus your expenses
equals zero have you done a budget
before
yes okay and i live off one right now
that's fantastic news well i'm going to
gift you uh every dollar premium as well
as financial peace university it's all
inside ramsay plus you'll get a one-year
subscription so hang on the line after
we're done austin will gift you that
because i want to help you walk through
this and get rid of this debt and get to
a place where you have a foundation
financially you can breathe is things a
little scarier right now a little tense
a little bit yeah yeah well you're not
scared of work and that gives me a lot
of hope for you because you're willing
to do whatever it takes to get out of
this debt and that's the most important
part so as you start attacking this debt
you have a thousand dollar emergency
fund as a buffer for all the ankle
biters you'll be in a better car
and then the rest of the money and all
future income every dime that's not
going towards you know keeping the
lights on and getting some basic needs
met your food utility shelter
transportation i want going towards that
debt
and making 55 000 maybe more if you ramp
up these side hustles i think you can
pay this debt off within a year does
that sound reasonable
maybe 18 months
yeah
can i ask you a question george here
um
so
what do you think of my uh i'm a little
bit scared um about the rent because i i
think really far into the future and you
know i just um i i kind of was was
thinking of saving up so that i have um
the entire rent covered for the year so
i don't have to worry about that do you
think that's a good line of thinking or
something i should get rid of i think
that's a little bit of fear and paranoia
and i think once you start following
these steps you get rid of the debt you
have that starter emergency fund and
eventually once you're out of debt have
a fully funded emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses you're going
to feel a whole lot better
now if you want to you can go and get a
roommate if you want to split you know
the cost are you is this a one bedroom
yeah it's a one bedroom okay you may
want to look at your option see if a two
bedroom is 1200 bucks well that brings
my cost down to 600. i don't think rent
is going to be the biggest issue right
now um i think getting rid of this debt
and getting on a firm financial
foundation is what's going to give you
that financial piece you're looking for
so hang on the line austin will pick up
we'll gift you one year of ramsay plus
get plugged into every dollar premium
connect it to your bank track your
transactions start attacking this debt
and call us back when you're debt-free
nicholas we're rooting for you man this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell host
of the fine print and entree leadership
podcast all of which you can find on the
ramsay network and wherever you listen
to podcasts flying solo today so uh keep
me company would you the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five and if you're wondering where
everyone went no the rapture didn't
happen okay
left behind as great of a movie as it is
did not take place there's no folded
clothes here they're just in orlando
they're at the entre leadership summit
event it's the final day some amazing
speakers john deloney spoke there today
jocko speaking this afternoon i'm a
little bit sad to not be there but the
folks in the booth and the folks in the
lobby they're keeping me company we're
having a good time
triple eight eight two five five two two
five okay so if you've been watching the
show for a little while you know that
we've added a fun new segment where we
do some reactions to some videos
floating out there on the internet a lot
of people think i'm just scouring tick
tock finding videos to hate on it's not
true our team does that
my friend zach in the booth that's what
he does it's his full-time job is to
just find things to get riled up about
isn't that what social media is for
these days and so we found a video
about mortgages and we get a lot of hate
for our take on mortgages that you
shouldn't have one
it's a hot take that you should pay your
mortgage off because
then you can really live and give like
no one else and build wealth so let's
watch this video and i'll let you know
my thoughts after
paying off your mortgage early isn't
always a great idea let me show you why
let's say that you have a three hundred
thousand dollar mortgage at a four
percent interest rate for thirty years
your payment is fourteen hundred dollars
you have an extra thousand dollars that
you can use to either pay off your
mortgage faster or invest let's look at
what happens in both cases if you use
your thousand dollars to pay off your
mortgage faster you'll pay off your
mortgage in 13 years and save 120k worth
of interest now start investing all of
that 2400 17 years later you'll have a
million dollars assuming an average
eight percent return now let's look at
if you invest a thousand dollars instead
of paying off your mortgage over the
same 30 years you'll pay 128 000 more in
interest but you'll have 1.4 million
dollars in investment paying off your
mortgage early would cost you 300 000 in
total wealth that's a lot of money sure
you've saved a bid on interest but you
lost money in the long run that's why
it's so important that you understand
the way personal finance actually works
that way you can crunch the numbers and
choose the path that makes the most
financial sense for you
oh
so that's how personal finance actually
works
oh my goodness well if i had known that
i would have gotten to way more debt
because apparently you can make millions
by going into debt and staying in debt
okay
a lot of numbers were thrown out there
you can you can ignore the numbers for
now it's too much to keep in your brain
i tried to write some of it down it's
just too much but here's the deal uh as
a guy who paid off his house and some
people have said well that was a dumb
thing to do you should have invested the
money listen it's hard enough for me to
sleep at night with everything going on
in the world but i sleep a whole lot
better knowing my home is paid for and i
don't owe anyone anything and here's the
thing people come at us and go well you
you still have taxes and insurance so
you'll always have payments
you must be real fun at parties if
that's how you think and talk to people
so when it comes to the mortgage you're
right on paper you can do better if life
works out perfectly for you and you
magically have an extra thousand dollars
sitting around which news alert most
americans don't because they're broke
then yes on paper if it works out
perfectly and you get your exact return
every single year
and you get that exact mortgage scenario
sure you could end up with a few hundred
grand more
but the truth is
99.9 of americans aren't doing that will
not do that can't do that they don't
have extra money laying around and if
you think that if i did have extra money
it would all go towards investing
because i'm such an astute investor
you're also wrong because we know
lifestyle creep happens life happens a
vacation pops up a wedding pops up a
funeral life just happens hvac goes out
and so what happens is the people that
do that generally don't have an
emergency fund don't have extra money
and if they do they're probably hanging
out in reddit threads you know talking
about how much dave doesn't know about
personal finance which is totally fine
you are entitled to your opinion it is a
free country and you're entitled to have
uh to be wrong
that's part of freedom so to that point
here's what i'll say that video is
clearly geared towards younger people
which frustrates me because young people
in their 20s are starting to fall for
these traps and they're starting to
believe that debt is a tool to be
leveraged and you can create so much
wealth by leveraging debt
and so to that i say what if we didn't
have payments and we invested the money
what would that turn into
how much life could we live in the
meantime before retirement before we
have 1.4 million dollars there's a lot
of life in between isn't there
we want to raise families we want to
send our kids to college debt-free we
want to go on amazing vacations we want
to give generously and what i have found
is that payments in your life hold you
back from doing all that in the meantime
over the next 30 years of your working
life
and so that is why i advocate for paying
off your mortgage early and we've
debunked many times the idea of the oh
you guys should hang on to your mortgage
for the tax deduction no we debunk this
all the time at our live events and
financial peace university you're
trading a dollar for a quarter if you're
keeping your mortgage around for the tax
deduction
because you want to pay your lender ten
thousand dollars instead of sending the
irs 2500 that's just bad math
so all that to say uh please stop making
videos that are hurting young people i
want them to win financially i want them
to live a debt-free life not only
because of the financial side but the
psychological side the spiritual side
we're seeing so much anxiety and
depression with these younger
generations and a huge part of that
is because of money fears
money problems money issues and so i
think if we can get rid of that aspect
we can then focus on other things we can
be more self-less focus on others more
find opportunities where we can help
others because we're not so focused and
dialed in on our own money problems so
that's my encouragement to you guys uh
take it
as you will that's tick tock for you and
joins us up next in tampa florida and
welcome to the show
hi how are you i'm doing great how can i
help today
so i had a question about um irs debt
and where
that should fall in the debt snowball
okay how much debt is this
well it's kind of hard to say because
it's never shown up in my account i've
you know i called them finally and it's
you know they just haven't finalized it
probably roughly about 15 000. okay is
this kind of back taxes or
um
no i
i get alimony and you know when i
was awarded the alimony i guess i didn't
realize you know
the taxes out of yeah so okay that kind
of got me in a mess for quite some time
i'm trying to get i'm still at the point
where every year you know i owe them
anywhere from seven to ten thousand
so i'm trying to get off the hamster
wheel are you working with a tax
professional right now or have you been
doing it yourself i finally did this now
by this year i went to um you know one
of the ramsey tax professionals and
you know he gave me some advice i just i
can't it's not really realistic right
now i basically need to make less income
need to make less income that's a i
don't like you know i need to invest
well because i because i i make like a
hundred and eight thousand
so i end up getting taxed
i don't know it's just a mess it's a hot
mess
bracket it's not like you owe that
entire amount
you would just owe the overage into that
new tax bracket
right and i've tried to you know i
usually do my paychecks i have an extra
150 or 200 taken out in taxes on that
and then i do you know i do all sorts of
stuff and i still end up even here with
7 200. okay well i'll let you work out
with your tax bro how much other debt do
you have
uh about
i have about 20 000 in a car
um
what's the car worth
probably about 20. i
probably am upside down on it because
the car broke down kind of before i got
in the program didn't have any emergency
fund to fix it so i had to so i you know
bought a new car
okay what other debt yeah that one and
so
uh credit cards of about
17 and student loans about 5500.
okay and you said your income is like
108.
yeah okay well we put irs debt at the
very top of the debt snowball because
you don't want that monkey on your back
and so we want to get rid of that one as
soon as possible so that's the one i
would focus on first and then i would
attack the rest of them and i would look
at selling the car if you're not
underwater on it
if you can use that 20k slap 15 there on
the irs deck get rid of it by a 5 000
car i like that plan a whole lot
that's my goal for you is to get through
this as fast as possible get rid of the
irs so you can focus on the rest of the
debt become debt free and now you're
making six figures with no payments that
is the future i want for you thanks so
much for the call in this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
well inflation is affecting everyone
right now from the gas bump to the
grocery store and while you can't
control what happens with the economy
you can control what happens with your
money and the only way to control your
money in uncertain times is to get on a
budget pay attention to where your
money's going and the best way to do
that is with every dollar with every
dollar you'll plan out your monthly
budget and track all of your expenses
throughout the month plus the every
dollar mobile app lets you check your
budget from anywhere so you can always
make the right money decisions and when
you get on a budget you will be in total
control of your money and you'll give
yourself a raise so start budgeting for
free today by going to
ramseysolutions.com
every dollar
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
to call travis joins us up next in
chattanooga tennessee travis welcome to
the show
hey george how you doing great how are
you
i'm doing well i'm just uh once if you
could answer my question i'm navigating
a little relationship advice here oh
okay this is fun what's going on
i've got the opportunity to sell the
current home i'm in this inflated market
and us move back to a rental property
and be completely debt free
my wife currently runs a business out of
our home due to the hoa the property
will be moving to she would no longer be
able to do that
but again there will be no mortgage so
there would be no need to have to do
this um
just trying to find a way to navigate it
peacefully so is this a side business
for her does she do this full time
um she does it full time but i'm the
primary breadwinner and it's just
something where she started doing in the
last three years and really found
fulfillment
and i hate taking that joy away from her
but
this thing i mean we'll both be fully
with no mortgage and no debt
now when you say no mortgage you'll be
renting at this new property
no this was my we were only this home
and when we moved to our current house
we've been renting this out and we had
the opportunity to take advantage of the
inflated market and pay off
um back rental property and live their
debt free
okay so how much debt do you guys have
um the only thing we have is the the two
mortgages and maybe about 14 000 credit
card debt
okay so
14k in credit card debt and you've got
two mortgages one on the spot you're
living in now and one on the rental
property
yes but you're saying if you sold your
current home you could pay off both
mortgages and the credit card debt
and walk away that's probably a net of
around 150 000
nice
i mean on paper this looks real good but
you're saying this is a relationship
issue because she's what she's not
wanting is well if we move i can't do
this business anymore
right and your argument is well you
won't need to
right you don't need the money
right she runs the pet sitting business
and i'm like volunteer shelters donate
your time you know there's no need to
have to do it for monetary gains and
she's been doing the pet sitting
business at the house
yes why can't she go to people's houses
in pet sit
that was my thing a lot of the
overnights i think her clients that
trust her and really value the
you know the professionalism that she
offers
would let her transition that into
overnights in their home instead of
having to bring them powers
does she want to turn this into like a
brick and mortar pet boarding business
one day or is this just kind of for fun
if
if it got busy enough yes and i've even
entertained the idea that
with no mortgage in your debt this may
be something that both her and i can
pursue without me having to even
continue my day-to-day
i think that's the selling point for me
if i'm you sitting in your shoes i'm
going to her saying hey i want you to
have the freedom to expand this thing
and really grow it and i know
temporarily it feels like we're moving
backwards but man not having any
payments that frees us up to do some
things
what's your household vehicles we both
paid cash for vehicles when we bought
those they're about seven years old and
then just really pretty much that small
credit card debt and the mortgages is
all we have left so what's the total
debt between the mortgages and the
credit card debt
um between the mortgages and the credit
card debt you're probably looking at
around
let's see quick estimate probably around
235
okay and how much could you sell the
house for
um around four
net after fees and closing everything
around 421
421 that's what you would net
that's and everything on the house yes
and that well then there's another then
after all that the 62 000 on paying the
rental off
okay
and so you're saying we'll crush the 235
in our debt we'll have a fully funded
emergency fund immediately
are you guys investing right now
yes we both have been investing in our
401ks now for quite a few years so we're
doing pretty well there okay well our
plan is you don't invest until you've
got the consumer debt paid off so you're
doing things a little bit out of order
but uh what's your household income
um approximately
140. okay now if she stopped doing this
pet sitting business what would it go
down to
uh about 1 pm okay
now with 110 and no payments how much
margin would you guys have left at the
end of the month
oh ridiculous like a few thousand bucks
oh yeah i mean i i without even changing
spending habits we're probably saving
1600 a month
that's not bad
that would be my selling point to her i
think you start with the math but then
you appeal to the emotional side of what
this means for her dreams and does she
really does she want to continue doing
this or could she explore a different
career path altogether that she's more
passionate about and so i would look at
it as what kind of options does this
give us as a family
okay
and uh if if she says heck no you're if
this is going to be a real rift in the
relationship then i don't know that it's
worth going through this process i mean
you guys aren't broke right
no you could still pay off your debt and
do all that while living where you live
we could but you know
you know with the way that the economy
is looking now you know you're we're one
slip away from a pretty good financial
collapse and i would like to be
preemptive as possible i think you you
pitch that to her too and say hey i
don't feel like we're financially secure
with these
double mortgage payments we're making
every month and man what would it feel
like to have not a payment in the world
and the world is our oyster now and you
can pursue what you want are you guys
moving to a different town or is this
still in the same area
um it's relatively close okay
so it's not like you're uprooting your
life you're not moving to
you know des moines going hey this is
this will be great for us we're still
keeping your life
it's been great for the most part
because we've had the same renter since
we've moved out of the house so it's
been contingent on us not having to
cover two mortgages as long as we had
winners in and i've always told her that
was something that wasn't in place
then you're looking at us covering two
mortgages now we would have
nothing to worry about now are you going
to kick this tenant out that's living
there right now
yes i've already spoke with them and
they're looking for other
other places to okay good
well this sounds like a pretty clean
break for me if i'm in your shoes i'm
doing it but to your point this is a
harder conversation with your wife and
you she's got to be on board you can't
do this against her will and so finding
out get to the root of what her fears
are
maybe you guys go on a date and go hey
what's really going on here
because i want the best for you i want
you to do what you want to do with your
career and if that's pet sitting we're
going to find a way to do it and when we
don't have debt we're going to have way
more ways to do it even if temporarily
we can't do it inside the home
right yeah and people will always be
willing to pay good money to have their
pets taken care of even their horses
yeah it surprised me how well the
business took off as quickly as it has
that's awesome well i think you you look
on paper and go hey how could we grow
this business you start helping her
dream about what this could turn into
and then it's less about selling the
house as the point of contention and it
becomes more about how can we get to
where you want to go
so i would set that vision with her and
get on the same page get on the same
plan
and show her the numbers that's part of
it i don't know how much math is going
to appeal to her because right now it
sounds like it's a lot there's a lot of
emotion tied to this
oh you guys when i when i you know start
breaking down the math she's like i get
i get the numbers and then she starts
going back emotionally on
what having to be given up
yeah
well i think this is a temporary setback
for her
that eventually is going to turn into
something great i can't wait for you to
call back and go man she started her own
pet boarding business it's brick and
mortar she's crushing it she's making
more than me i've joined her in the
business and life is great
sounds great that's my hope for you man
thank you so much for the call
that's a tough one
a lot of people
call in and the numbers make sense the
math works out but there's a relational
piece that you have to grapple with you
got to go how do we get on the same page
and this looks different for everyone
for some people just doing the math just
showing them the interest we're throwing
away on our payments that can be enough
to get you riled up for me it is because
i'm a giant nerd for a lot of people you
get to appeal to the emotions get to the
root of it help them dream about the
future instead of worrying about the
present and all kinds of fears but you
got to get to the root of the problem
the real route if you want to get
somewhere together and that's my hope
for everyone because once you get on the
same page man you are an unstoppable
couple who's going to charge hell with a
water pistol
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and i
am your host today
ryden solo it's free call triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
talk about your life and your money
christina joins us up next in chicago
christina welcome to the show
thank you for having me absolutely
what's going on with you
um so i'm just starting to
get started here and try and figure out
a budget and i was wondering how do you
plan
or budget in expenses for a newborn i
have a four month old currently so i'm
just trying to figure out how you
put that into your uh monthly budget fun
congratulations
thank you so four months old how's it
been going
pretty good
and how have you covered expenses so far
have you kind of just been winging it
and you're going i don't know if i'm
doing this right
yeah pretty much okay well you know when
you have the newborn it's just going to
add a line item to your budget so it
shouldn't add you know thousands of
dollars every month you're probably
looking at a few hundred bucks so far
does that sound right
yeah pretty much it's not it hasn't been
too bad luckily um but yeah i'm just
starting to kind of figure out when we
start doing daycare and everything like
that how to just kind of yeah do you
guys have any debt
uh yes how much we we have about 75 000
in student loans
30 in a car and about five in credit
cards
okay and what's your income
about 120.
cool
and what does care look like right now
for that four month old
uh well my husband's a teacher so he'll
be offered this summer so we're not
we don't figure out care until august
but we got some estimates and that's
looking at about like
a thousand dollars a month is that the
part that's kind of stressing you out
going how do we even fit this in the
budget
yeah pretty much because i'm guessing
right now you don't have an extra
thousand dollars laying around
no we're pretty tight um i'm sorry to
hear that
so i think
if we got rid of this debt life would
feel a lot more peaceful wouldn't it
absolutely okay
so i want that to be your focus now the
baby's home baby's healthy right
yes and so outside of the basic budget
line items we don't need to go get all
the fancy tech for the baby it's gonna
be okay but i would start making a list
of all the things that are monthly
expenses and then make a list of things
that are maybe yearly expenses or kind
of a sinking fund things like checkups
doctor visits things like that where you
know it's coming up you know what your
co-pays are going to be you kind of know
how often you're going to be visiting
you know what you know basic clothing is
going to cost and all of that
so once that's in the budget i would
start going okay what is it going to
take to create a thousand dollars worth
of margin
by august or by september
right and once you do that it kind of
gets you to be creative and you start
making a plan going all right what areas
could we shave what are the expenses
right now and that might mean
getting uh you know your husband taking
on a side job outside of teaching can he
work this summer
uh yeah he can okay
so what if he could pick up a job and he
could save up 12 grand
or start paying off some of this debt to
free up some of these payments so that
you could find this thousand dollars in
your budget
right now that's a good idea and so i
think when you start getting creative
going all right if we know debt is off
the table we're not going further into
debt we want to clean up this mess what
does it look like to find a thousand
dollars a month
and
i think then that's when you start to go
what are these expenses what can we
shave down what can i go get at goodwill
what can i borrow from a friend what is
any way to stop spending money and then
what are some ways we can make more
money
and once you add those together and you
get rid of this debt which i'm looking
at how much is this car worth
um probably about 36. okay
uh
this this might hurt but i think right
now this baby takes precedence over
driving a nice car would you agree
yeah we had gotten it because we my car
was
had a hundred thousand miles on into
2014 so we bought the new car last year
and
thinking that we were going to need it
for the baby
well i'll tell you this you sell that
car for 36 000
and you owe 30. that gives you six grand
maybe scrape up some extra money and get
an eight grand car
and uh the baby's gonna be just as safe
in that car as a 36 000 car
yeah that's what i was thinking
and so that to me already gives me a
little bit of peace because you just
knocked out a huge chunk of almost a
third of your debt right there
right
and now we're going okay we have the
student loans we can knock out these
credit cards real quick and then we just
have the student loans so now you've
freed up a car payment and the credit
card payment what do those add up to
the credit card and the car payment yeah
uh that would be about 35.
what does that mean for the years okay
for the year so what is that up to in
your monthly budget what are those
payments that you're making every month
uh for the car it's 500 and the credit
card um
is probably about 250. okay so now i'm
going oh my gosh we just found 750 on
our budget you just gave yourself a
raise
and now with a side job if we can just
get an extra 250 a month we can afford
daycare no problem and now we just have
the student loans do you see you feel
the excitement when you start to knock
out some of this debt and get those
payments out of your life
absolutely okay
so that would be my plan i'm finding any
way to make more to spend less to get
rid of this debt as soon as possible and
if i'm you guys i'm selling the car and
that might hurt for now but i promise
you the babies just as safe in that car
obviously get something fairly reliable
i'm not asking you to drive a beater
around but an 8 000 old minivan suv
whatever it is will get you around just
fine and remember this is temporary
because you're going to get an upgrade
once you're out of debt you have a fully
funded emergency fund daycare's taken
care of now we can go upgrade that car
thank you so much for the call gavin
joins us up next in kansas gavin welcome
to the show
hi george hey thanks for having me
absolutely what's going on
well um i have a dilemma here and i
wanted to run it by you
i'm my question is whether i should take
this next semester off of school or kind
of contort college in a way that would
make it feasible and in my particular
situation i'm 21 years old i've got one
more year left i'm in june just got done
my junior year awesome and i'm
completely debt free thanks to the baby
steps borrowing money is not on the
table just want to make that clear
fantastic but i'm in sales right now
i
sell vehicles general motors and so i'm
in a sales position now however uh with
my classes being more nuanced for senior
year to graduate they're right in the
middle of the day and with scheduling um
it appears that i'm not going to be able
to make the amount of sales that's going
to allow me to continue cash flowing
school
okay what is it going to cost
for this last year the cost
yep the cost for school is 19 000 per
year or about 1500 a month okay and
you've got no money right now do you
have any money saved up i've got about
800 bucks 800 bucks to your name
no debt though
no debt okay
so
is there anything else you could do at
night
choose a different sales job to keep the
income going
i could i could um i could do some side
hustles like pizzas or something like
that
yeah my thought though it
when i am not in school my income uh
track record has been probably about 5
000 a month or so
um when i'm not in school that's me just
focusing grinding 60 hours a week at my
my job and so i'm i'm toying around with
this idea of taking a semester off to
save up some money uh so that way i can
continue cash flowing
yeah yeah i mean i think that's that's
your last ditch option i don't know that
it would be my first i'm going to try to
cash flow this thing are you working
this summer
yes i am okay could you work this summer
and really grind and get 19k saved up
and just pay or pay for a semester at a
time
i i could i could i think um they're
looking at what eight out of a little
cup nine grand about nine grand a
semester
yes okay so my thing is can you get nine
grand for the summer to pay for the
semester then during the semester work
more to save up another nine grand to
pay for the final one
i probably could it's probably going to
be pretty tight
well i'm okay with tight if it means
you're graduating and once you're you've
graduated completely debt-free and
you're graduating you know at least six
months earlier
that's true so i think that's my first
option and if you're going this is
impossible i don't want it to burn you
out but dude you're young you're 21.
you've got more energy than i do at this
point so that would be my goal is to do
whatever i could to find any side
hustles it doesn't have to be sales
anything where you can make a lot of
money quickly
i'd be focusing on that and if you can
get through school debt free without
taking a gap i'm good with that if you
have to take the gap i'm still proud of
you for graduating debt free so either
options great with me just don't go into
debt and uh you'll thank us all later
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to austin and
will and kelly zach and andrew in the
booth keeping the show afloat and you
america appreciate you guys listening
we'll be back with you before you know
it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career
and get on the path to living well
i'm george campbell and i will be your
host today flying solo as the rest of
our team finishes out the entree
leadership summit event with about 3 000
business leaders in orlando florida it's
been a great time there as our team has
been watching the live stream back home
here jocko is taking the stage right now
pretty epic i'm pretty much baby jocko
i've been told that in the past kelly's
looking at me with a face so we're just
gonna get to the phones here free call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's talk about your life and your
money let me help you take the right
next step
and work through whatever you're working
through
john joins us up first this hour in
grand rapids john welcome to the show
hey how you doing i'm doing great how
are you
i am overwhelmed but still way better
than what i should ever be
that's a beautiful time
let me help you get well today how's
that
that sounds
absolutely fantabulous
um what's going on in your situation
quick breakdown both my wife and i are
20.
my wife is six months pregnant um grew
and of course about three
months um
we had
so about three months ago we started to
remodel the house with
about with money that we had above and
beyond our emergency fund well since
then we've had
about seven to eight thousand dollars
worth of unexpected bills come up
and i got a
new truck to me now to sell my old one
i should have been able to make a couple
grand and i did that i was hey speak
directly in your phone for me john
you're cutting in and out
isn't this a little bit better yes
okay okay so you've got a new to you
truck
yeah all right that's where you left off
okay um paid six grand for it my
old one should have been able to sell
for eight
and uh
cannot sell it
and that was
the stupid part was that was supposed to
be our emergency fund with that i was
expecting a quick foot
on my old truck quick sell
but it's not selling and we have
absolutely no
money now in our uh
in our savings because of that and
my wife informed me this morning that
she needed tires like
yesterday and so i checked it out and we
had to get herself a brand new set of
tires and
um
work right now is a little bit rocky i
just had my three-month enter
three-month meeting
and it did not go too hot and so i'm
scared to take over time
okay so let me recap here how much debt
do you guys currently have
um
just like 500 bucks from the tires from
this morning okay do you put those on a
credit card
yeah i did how much money do you have in
the bank
um
nickel and diming everything probably
about there um
we'll get rid of that little bit of debt
um by friday tomorrow my paycheck is
sitting
and uh
friday my wife is
okay so right now how much money do you
have in the bank
not counting the 500 credit card
that's about it okay so pretty much zero
dollars to your name currently until
this paycheck hits yeah
and you drain the emergency fund uh to
pay for these random emergencies plus
you paid for the truck with the
emergency fund hoping you'd flip the
other one
yeah okay so why can't you sell this
other truck that's worth a thousand
i have no idea i have it listed for
seven and no
there's absolutely no interest where is
it listening someone wants this
um i have it on 26 different groups on
facebook and facebook marketplace okay
have you checked with some of these
companies like carvana or room or local
dealerships to see what they would buy
it for
um
not a whole lot um there's
pretty much around me there's just a
whole bunch of little mom and pop
places
um
i'm gonna keep pushing to sell this
truck asap because right now it's just
sitting there right you have two trucks
yeah correct yeah
that's my age at all it hasn't been on
the road in three weeks is there
anything wrong with the truck are the
photos good
what do you think is wrong with it
why it's not selling you just
just typical cosmetic okay what's your
household income
uh right around 55.
okay
and your wife is currently working
correct will she work outside the home
once baby's here
um yeah she will she will take the first
little bit
um and stay home with the baby but she
she loves what she does too much she
said she doesn't think that she can stay
home so she'll go back to work
after maternity leave
correct okay well i know life has been
punching you in the face man but the
good news is you're you're not that far
in the hole you're 500 in debt when
these paychecks hit you'll be able to
pay that off and then your focus is
going to be saving up for this baby
so i want you to start working on that
fully funded emergency fund slash baby
fund and once baby is here and safe then
we can move on to our other goals but a1
in the next three months is to sell this
truck work your tail off to stack up as
much money as possible would that give
you some peace of mind and let you
breathe a little easier
well my my only concern with
um alex taking over time
is i'm already kind of rocky here with
this job so rocky is in what
i just had my three month interview last
week or sorry my interview review and it
was not too hot so you're basically on a
probationary type
period right now
yeah correct so they feel like you're
not performing at the level you should
be
correct what kind of work are you doing
construction okay
are there other construction jobs out
there that would pay equal or more
if this thing fell through
the answer is yes it was a trick
question john
there are some there's not a whole lot
um
most people around here they've all
worked with each other the previous guy
that i worked with everyone knew that i
worked with them and they wouldn't even
return my phone calls because they
wanted to honor my previous employer
okay well i'm gonna do what i can to not
biff this job here and then on top of
that i'm gonna go find other side
hustles maybe outside of construction
maybe it's handyman work i don't know
what your skill set is but find
something that can pay you know 20 25
bucks an hour in this market i think
that's really reasonable and for the
next this is temporary remember but for
the next three months your job is to
stack up as much money as possible avoid
going into debt because once this 500
bucks is gone you're in baby step three
working on the emergency fund and kind
of taking this pause to go we got to
stack up money for this baby make sure
mom and baby are healthy and then we can
take a deep breath and figure out what
life looks like
yeah but right now there's no time for
excuses there's no time for a well i
don't know if there's dude you've got to
be hustling grinding because you're
about to be a dad and i want you to be
able to take care of your family and do
it with some dignity
so that's my a1 if i'm in your shoes i
feel the pressure man i'm not trying to
say this is going to be easy but for 90
days if you can just dial in and focus
and i want to help you get there i'm
going to gift you one year of ramsay
plus so hang on the line austin will
pick up it includes financial peace
university it includes every dollar
premium our budgeting tool
that will give you some peace of mind
some control over where your money's
going and some next steps that's what i
want for you good luck with the baby
hope for everything to go smoothly
healthy and happy for you all
and thanks for the call man this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality and i
will be your host this hour
open phones triple eight eight two five
five two two five that is the number to
call let's talk about your life and your
money marie is up next in seattle marie
welcome to the show
hi thank you absolutely what's going on
with you
um i've been budgeting for my husband
and i've been budgeting
and we're trying to get rid of our debt
and we're trying to do like the snowball
effect but i was wondering we have three
credit cards with the total amount of
debt for those credit cards around 12
grand i think right now okay um would it
be
more beneficial to
add put all those credit cards onto one
all those balances onto one credit card
versus having three separate payments
no
what do you think the benefit is
you know i wasn't sure if having them on
one credit card
would lower the amount of interest but i
wasn't sure if the
cash is because it's considered a cash
advance when you pay off something like
that i wasn't sure if that interest rate
would end up charging more
i mean in rare scenarios you might get a
better interest rate but right now what
i love about them being separated is you
feel the progress
if you're staring at one mountain of
twelve thousand dollars it kind of takes
your breath away a little bit but when
you see one that's 3 000 you see one
that's 5 000 you go okay let's attack
the small one first let's get rid of
that payment it frees up some money then
let's attack the next one frees up a
little bit more money and then you see
the light into the tunnel you go oh my
gosh we can do this stuff and so that's
why i'm not a fan of consolidation when
it comes to
general consumer debt what's your income
household um around 60 000 okay
and is this all of your debt or is there
other debt that you have
no there's other debt we don't have any
car debt um
we have student loans i think he has
about 5 000 and i have
11.
okay
so if i'm you guys i'm gonna list this
out from smallest to largest and roll
with the debt snowball method which
means
the credit cards the student loans we're
going to lump these all in a giant list
and list them out from smallest to
largest and we're not going going to
write down the interest rate we don't
care about that right now because i want
you to feel some momentum and some
progress
so what's the smallest debt
um one of the credit cards and i think
it's
three grand three grand okay now how
much margin do you guys have left at the
at the end of the month after making all
of your minimum payments and covering
all of your bills
i think
like 400 dollars
okay so you have 400 extra to put on
that first small instead of 3 000
yeah so if we do that for let's just say
we stay status quo as is we're talking
about
six seven months to get rid of this
first debt
correct
okay
now my question is how do we speed this
up because i i i'm okay with sacrifice
for a short time but i want it to be as
quick as possible so what does it look
like to get your income up right now or
to cut expenses
to cut expenses is it's just new for me
to cut
i i'm not really a spender um but we had
a baby like a lot of your people today
um
thank you yeah so i'm a stay-at-home mom
but i'm also working as a college intern
um and i get to pick my hours so lately
i've been
working more hours or trying to work
more hours so we can get more income and
then my husband's also working overtime
that's awesome what is the does the
internship pay
yes okay what does that pay
um
16 29 an hour i think okay and that's
part of the 60 grand household income
yeah and then what does your husband do
he's a correctional officer cool can he
work overtime
yes and he is
can he work even more over time
he could yes i like this plan a lot
because then i go okay you have 400 of
margin what if we had 600 how would that
speed up the process what if we had 800
yeah and so that's where you start to
get excited and not feel like this is a
slog and most people i found they pay
off the all of their consumer debt
within 18 to 24 months if they follow
our plan
if you if you do the math on this and
you do that at snowball you list it all
out and you go this is going to take us
three years then that tells me we've got
to change something
we've got to up the income we've got to
cut every subscription we're not getting
cable we're selling the tv we're selling
the couch we're sitting on a folding
chair whatever we've got to do to get
out of debt as fast as possible
okay
have you guys been doing a monthly
budget on paper
yeah i've been doing not on paper um i
made like a budget on excel and the
thing is i haven't been following it
lately i've been spending a little bit
more because things have been more
pricey and
i just stopped looking at it because
avocados went up from seven dollars to
twelve dollars
in a pack so time to not get avocados i
guess
yeah time to find a different vegetable
maybe we go potatoes this this week this
month yeah so that's what i'm going to
do i guess we could cut back on stuff
like that here's what i want you to do
i'm going to gift you every dollar
premium because it beats i know i don't
want to stare an excel spreadsheet
that's depressing let's leave the pivot
tables to the nerds
so every dollar is going to make it a
lot simpler for you to create this
budget to stick to it and that's the key
is you can't just make it and then look
back at it a month later and go oh
whoops we went over before you make the
purchase i want you to look at your
budget and go okay we've got this much
left i'm going to make sure to not go
over in that category
and give yourself some grace it may take
a few months to get the hang of this but
once you do you're going to feel way
more in control of your money
so hang on the line austin's gonna pick
up and we'll gift you guys ramsey plus a
one-year subscription that includes
every dollar premium our budgeting tool
and financial peace university so watch
those videos with your husband and i
think it'll get you fired up to get rid
of this debt and get real creative to
find any way you can to make it not a
three four year slog but you guys can do
this this is not a giant mountain i mean
it's it's a little less than half of
your income and i think if you get that
up you'll feel the progress thank you so
much for the call
chad joins us up next in minneapolis
chad welcome to the show
yeah thanks for having me absolutely
what's going on
well
looking for some advice on how to make
an impact with my 14 year old son so um
divorced
from my ex we got divorced about three
years ago
i've i've really been in on the ramsey
method and got myself out of debt
following the divorce
really gotten into saving and and being
very intentional with my money
i'm proud of you man that's awesome
yeah 14 year olds with being
impressionable and thinking they've got
to have x y and d to be cool
he
my i my ex has very
poor spending habits and
you know
car every a new car every 18 months
um you know racks up credit cards so she
has a very flashy lifestyle
from the outside but i i because i was
there for 15 years i know
without having to see your checkbook
what the
backside looks like
how do i
show how do you influence your team to
not be like their mom
to not be like their mom yeah without
without
piercing my own veil to say hey yep i i
have a truck that you make fun of but
it's bought and paid for and oh by the
way for the last three years while i'm
driving a a car that's got 270 000 miles
on it
i i've put away an extra 60 000 because
of it well the truth is a 14 year old
has no perception of money and so they
just see the fancy thing they don't care
what it costs they don't care how much
debt you have because they don't have
any money problems right now
and so obviously we don't want to
disparage your ex we want to be kind uh
but we also want to just focus on what
we can control and that's ourselves so i
think you focus on the principles and
not the person
so focus on here's why i live a
debt-free lifestyle
here's what it can do for you here's
what i want for you in your future
maybe you show them you know the
documentary borrowed future and go hey
this is what happens when you live a
lifestyle that includes debt it holds
you back from having a family buying the
things that you want and it they may
look good on the outside but man their
life is stressful and then ask have you
ever been stressed what are you stressed
out about right now that's the kind of
stress that debt is going to add to your
life and i want the best for you so if
you start to have those kinds of
conversations i found that more is
caught than taught and that 14 year old
as their brain starts to mold further
they're going to want to be like dad
more than mom eventually it may not
happen tomorrow
because right now if i'm 14 i want the
flashy car
but right now they don't have an income
and so they're they hopefully can't make
terrible financial decisions but as they
get closer your job is to be a great
role model a great influence in their
life to be a level-headed voice of truth
and that's all you can do and the rest
you got to let go of and there might be
a conversation with the ex and say hey
listen i'm trying to teach these
principles i want the best for a 14 year
old i'm sure you do too and that's what
this looks like
and maybe that means we're not talking
about money and how they should build
their credit
leave that to dad
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
there's so much crazy going on and
people are looking for direction on how
to handle their finances day to day but
they're also struggling to see how it's
even possible to build wealth
there's too many hope stealers out there
and that's why i'm excited for our
building wealth live events where we
walk you through all the crazy and teach
you the steps to build a real lasting
wealth
the financial principles we teach here
are the only principles that work in
prosperous times and in hard times and
no matter where you are with your money
today we want to show you that you can
get on the path to building wealth the
building wealth live tour has already
made a couple of awesome stops in vegas
and orlando thank you all for joining us
there and we're wrapping up our spring
portion of the tour here
and we're just getting started we've got
a few stops planned for this fall
so if you're in any of the following
cities we'd love to see you out there or
if you want to travel we've got lots of
people that drive hours fly to make it
to these events so phoenix will be with
you september 13th sacramento will be
with you november 1st we'll be at
minneapolis november 10th and finishing
out in san antonio november 15th dave
ramsey rachel cruz dr john deloney ken
coleman and i will all be there we can't
wait to see you guys tickets start at
just 25 bucks or you can get a four pack
of tickets starting at 60 bucks so bring
your friends it's going to be amazing go
to ramseysolutions.com
events to reserve your seats now
open phones this hour the number to call
is 888-825-5222
mike joins us up next in dayton mike
welcome to the show
thank you
what's going on i have a uh well i have
a job dilemma
i am doing something i sort of enjoy in
terms of uh i've been an engineer and
i've been teaching and consulting doing
engineering work on the side for some
time
a couple years actually
um consulting has gone really well
but at times it's kind of worn me out
i've been stretched then working seven
days a week for some stretches
and i have an opportunity now to kind of
go back to a more traditional
engineering type of role it would
essentially double my base pay
probably
similar to what i'm making consulting or
more
but only working one job
they put me on the road a couple weeks a
month
and i guess i'm just uh kind of in a
dilemma about
the path to choose here
i'm 50 years old and i i feel like i'm
in my prime earning years and i don't
want to shortchange
you know the generations that follow
since i'm
you know if i'm not working you know and
making the most i should be making at
this time of my life so the pro is you
get to work half as much and get paid
the same amount
i wouldn't say half as much no i would
say actually i
okay so the second that the engineering
job actually will probably in the end
work a little more
um the one i'm working now i'm finally
at the point where i'm kind of getting
caught up and i'm not uh not working the
seven day schedule anymore i'm starting
to slow it down a little bit but i'll
probably end up making less money so
basically i'll have a better schedule
make less money
versus making more money and
being able to you know leave a little
bit more solve one more financial so
you're taking a slight pay cut but you
get your life back
where i'm at now i'd be taking a slight
pay cut yeah if i took the job i would
um
be getting more time on the road
um
less of my life and of course more money
are you single
[Music]
no no married
um
two kids have just essentially they've
left home yeah they're in the area but
essentially they've left home uh they're
in their 20s what does your spouse think
about this
uh she's kind of on the fence as well
we are debt free
uh we're both uh about 50 years old we
don't have a house payment at this point
we've
awesome that our net worth is up and i
think we're and when we followed a lot
of the ramsey principles for about took
about 17 years from having nothing to to
be in it
i don't know guess what the house about
1.1 million wow way to go man
so what i'm hearing is you don't
necessarily need the money
uh not necessarily no it's more for i
think i guess legacy purpose
um
i guess i'm kind of i'm kind of driven
by that just because i feel like what
does legacy look like
well it's not certainly not just
financial but it's
it's about
kind of changing the direction and
that's already happened with one
generation but i really feel like
i want to be involved in
changing direction for multiple
generations and i think that you know
part of that is the financial
yeah
i mean i think you guys are already
doing that i don't know that taking this
job or staying with this one is going to
change that very much i'm just wondering
does your wife want you at home more
versus being gone half the month
as the kids are out of the house yeah i
think
yeah
at least so far i think she would prefer
me at home could you find something
that's just you know 40 hours a week
local that you could do for the same pay
or more
have you looked into options
yeah i actually think um
oh i certainly could um
i think you know i'm fortunate enough to
have
pretty high demand skill set at this
point i think so
being on the road is fun if you're a
young single guy some people are built
for that to be on the road that much but
at your age with where you're at in life
i don't think it's something that you're
you're jonesing for does that excite you
to be on the road
not to be on the road the work excites
me being on the road doesn't um i don't
have any particular
any particular love affair with
being away from home and that that's
lost its cool factor a long time ago and
that's why i go i think you need more
options right now you feel kind of
backed into a corner where you go it's
either this or that and i think there's
more options out there for a sharp guy
who's 50 with your experience in the
engineering field which as you know our
our millionaire study that we did
engineers were the number one
millionaire career and so
that tells me you've got a great head on
your shoulders and there's a lot of
great engineering jobs and i'm sure
there's ones in your area that are a
little more sustainable for your
lifestyle at this point and you can
still leave a legacy whatever that looks
like for you without having to be on the
road all the time
and without a pay cut
yeah i think oh well that's definitely
true i actually think the gel that would
be on the road even though that's
there's road stuff to it actually i
think it provides more flexibility for
me schedule wise than um the traditional
40-hour job now do both jobs have equal
kind of benefits
uh yeah benefits are similar um
benefits are similar i
i probably would be able to put an extra
by my numbers probably an extra five
grand a year in 401k
um
but i'm you know at this age the extra
500 years certainly matters but i don't
know once i'm already built up pretty
well if it's going to be that big a
factor it's life-changing
yeah well i think you have this
conversation with your wife and i think
you've got some homework to find out
what the other options out there maybe
you start getting some interviews with
other
places locally
i don't know what kind of engineering
are you in
i'm an electrical engineer i do a lot of
a lot of automation work
yeah a lot of automation a lot of
industrial security and networking
cool well i'm going to keep doing
research i'm going to go into research
mode and find out what all the options
are who wants to hire mike in today's
market and what do those pay what makes
sense for my family and the truth is you
don't need the money you're not
desperate so i'm going to find something
that's sustainable for the next you know
10 years however long you choose to work
that won't burn you out and so that's
the route i'm going because you guys
have done the hard work you've
sacrificed to get to this point you've
got a paid for house the kids are out
and now it's like what what is the
vision we want for the next 10 years the
next 20 years and start making decisions
through that filter
okay
absolutely mike
he's he's got the dilemma man that's a
tough one uh there's no right or wrong
answer here and the truth is a guy as
sharp as you if you take the on the road
job and six months later you go this
ain't it chief you can go find something
else and uh i think a lot of places
would be happy to hire an electrical
engineer who has no debt
no debt hanging on their shoulders who's
just happy to be an electrical engineer
so thank you so much for that call
open phones this hour the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five i'm george campbell ramsey
personality and host of the fine print
and entree leadership podcast if you
wanna check out those other shows then
you can do that on the ramsey network or
wherever you listen to great podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
this is the ramsay show i'm george
campbell ramsey personality your host
this hour
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com find out for yourself why
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
just use the promo code ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from jake in california
he says i'm confused about your
recommendation to invest 15 percent of
our household income do my wife and i
each invest seven and a half percent
into our 401k to meet the fifteen
percent rule for baby step four
sounds too easy when i type it out so i
need some clarification
well jake yeah you're probably
overthinking this so here's an easy way
to do it
fifteen percent of your household income
means you invest 15 of your income and
she invests 15
of her income
and as a total that adds up to 15 of
your household income
so no need to overcomplicate it you
don't have to do seven and a half each
if you make 40 and she makes 60 just
take 15
of both of those and invest that into
your 401k uh good question it does come
up uh more often than not and it's
simpler than you think it means exactly
what it sounds like and it's simple but
it's hard to do and that's why we teach
people in baby step four once you're out
of consumer debt once you have the fully
funded emergency fund that is the time
to invest 15
a lot of people call in they're doing 17
things at once they're trying to pay off
some debt they're trying to get the
match because it's free money
they're trying to save up the emergency
fund trying to save up for a down
payment on a house at a car and they're
wondering why they're not making
progress
and so that is why we teach baby step 4
15
into retirement at baby step 4 and no
earlier
and 15 is not 20 because we want to have
margin to save for college pay off the
house early
and once we do that we can increase that
and really build wealth thank you so
much for the question
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five connie joins
us up next in virginia connie welcome to
the show
hi thank you for having me happy to take
your call what's going on
so i recently found out my car is kind
of on its last legs i'm driving a beater
06 minivan um
and she doesn't have much time left but
does she have a name
uh she doesn't oh that's sad you gotta
give him a name yes give him some
dignity
she's just a she for now um
but i wasn't able to get an estimate on
exactly how much time that means but i'm
in step two
and i've made
significant progress well to me it is um
in paying off my debt i have my thousand
dollars emergency funds
but i've started saving for a car also
because
if she goes out on me i have no way to
get to work so um
i was wondering my question is should i
cut back on paying off debt and go back
to minimum payments
on all my accounts to
be able to save up for the car in case
it does go out
um or should i keep kind of
splitting 50 50 how much money i'm
pouring into those
yes i would definitely this is your a1
is to save up for this car and if that
means pausing that snowball temporarily
then i'm okay with that i just don't
want you to get too comfortable where
you go well it's been seven months and
i'm still saving up for this car this is
like an emergency where we're going how
do i find four that five thousand
dollars in a few months to be able to
switch cars so is this thing in the shop
what do you mean by last leg you've got
an estimates on it
uh i got a second opinion but both
people i took it to said this is gonna
be i probably have through the summer
through the summer so wow they're
putting a life expectancy on this thing
right that's dark time but they weren't
able to say if that means through the
winter also or it could go out in two
months or six and there's no there's no
use in trying to repair the issue it's
probably worth more than the car at that
point no it's a engine issue and i got
the car for three thousand
and how much money do you have to your
name you said you have a thousand dollar
emergency fund anything else
uh i have a thousand dollar emergency
fund i have
right under a thousand saved for the car
so far which i started um just last
month i've been really trying to focus
on that
i make about 2500 a month
what do you do for a living
um i'm a peer recovery specialist and an
addiction recovery clinic
cool
and that 2 500 a month is that take-home
pay or is that gross
that's take-home okay so you're taking
home about 30 grand a year and you're
working 40 hours a week
correct okay is there anything you can
do beyond that 40 hours to bring in
extra income right now
yes i have started um i do make up for
weddings for bridesmaids and stuff on
the weekends and that's not a consistent
booking though it's kind of when i can
get it when it's needed but when i can
do that i can make a couple hundred on a
saturday so good well i would do that on
top of something that's steady where
they just go hey how many hours can you
work this week all right you can give us
15 hours let's go do that and make 20
bucks an hour to save up for this car
and then once you're out of debt you can
stop doing all the side hustles that you
want maybe continue the makeup one if
you enjoy it
so that's what i would start doing is
looking for ways to increase income make
your minimum payments on your debt and
once this car situation is remedied then
we can get after the rest of the debt so
what's the total debt that you have
um i have a little over 40 000 left to
pay off what kind of debt
it's all medical debt oh wow how old is
the medical debt
um
up to i already had one they were all
several in collections and a couple fell
off so they were over seven years old
but how old are they
up from about five years too recently
wow
well the silver lining with medical debt
is that it can often be negotiated have
you tried to negotiate it down and ask
them what they would take in a lump sum
i did that um with the more recent ones
i haven't done that with the ones in
collections yet um i was able to get
financial aid for more recent stuff but
the old debt
was
i have not tried to negotiate or settle
that yet okay
there are some kind of hardship programs
and income based programs that you can
look into with these hospitals because
sometimes if your income is below a
certain threshold they may wipe out the
debt
okay so maybe something to just look
into i don't know for sure in your area
and which hospital and the medical bills
but i want you to really get creative
and do some research and do all that you
can to negotiate this debt down so that
if they go hey you got 40 grand in debt
we'll take 10 to call it good and at
that point you got to have that money
ready and so i would stack up money get
the car remedied and then stack up more
money so that when they come at you with
a here's our lump sum if you can pay
this we'll wipe it i would go for that
okay and that will get you out of debt a
whole lot faster
yeah i hate to
slow down on the debt to save for the
car because this has been such a big
step for me
i'm in recovery from addiction myself
and i have spent the last few years
piecing my life back together and
getting financial freedom is a huge step
for me so i'm not excited about slowing
down my debt-free journey to do this car
thing but wow well connie you are a
warrior and i love that you're now
helping others get on the path to
recovery
thank you that's so cool that that's a
lot of meaning and purpose in that kind
of work and we're rooting for you i want
to gift you ramsey plus which includes
every dollar premium and financial peace
university i hope that encourages you
encourages you along the journey
and allows us to kind of walk with you
through this process
and allows you to start to budget even
more get that budget dialed in to where
you go okay i can spend less i can save
more here's what the budget looks like
i'm tracking it i'm giving every dollar
a job and you feel some control over
your situation so hang on the line
austin's gonna pick up and gift that to
you and watch the financial peace
university lessons as well on there and
i think that will give you some pep in
your step uh along this debt-free
journey and please would you call us
back when you're debt-free or come visit
us
yes thank you
love to hear that
rooting for you connie what a cool story
recovering addict now helping others get
on the path to recovery cleaning up this
debt we love to hear stories like that
wow
well as you know folks there's a lot
going on in the world right now
and financial peace is a huge part of it
and i was just on our local
fox affiliate fox nashville here talking
about
inflation and what to do with your 401k
and how to find margin in your budget
and we acknowledge that it's not easy
right now
it's easy to give you some blanket
advice and tell you hey go follow the
baby steps but we know people are really
really struggling right now and uh we're
rooting for you and if we can help in
any way please check out all the
resources we have at ramseysolutions.com
we would love to be of service to you
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books my thanks to all the folks
in the booth austin will zach kelly
andrew you name it they're in there
making it happen day after day and some
engineers in there too and you america
appreciate you guys listening we
couldn't do the show without you we love
you we'll be back with you before you
know it
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
from ramsay network this is the ramsay
show where we help you get control of
your money get ahead in your career and
get on the path to living well i'm
george campbell your host today
and uh the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'd love to help you take the right next
step in your financial journey
matt is kicking us off this hour in
denver colorado
matt welcome to the show
thanks george how are you i'm doing
great how can i help
well um
my household has three vehicles
two that i have over a hundred thousand
miles on it and one has about 66 000
miles
one's about ready to die the
transmission's going out i'd like to buy
a new car and my wife would like to buy
a used car
ah
okay what's what's forcing you to get a
new car
well no nothing's forcing me to get a
new car but you know the one with the
transmission problems i'm thinking it it
could die on us at any time
okay
so what i'd like to
what's the argument with her saying i
want to use car and you want the new car
what's the contention
well uh she's a super saver i'm a saver
and
we we've saved all our lives and i would
just like to
you know
i think a new car would be better
because the used car prices are pretty
inflated right now and we have the money
to do it
what's your net worth
we have uh
well over
i would say close to three million
assets wow good for you guys
thanks so have you been following the
ramsey plan do you guys have a paid for
house in baby step seven
we do
wonderful news
well i mean you guys have scratch and
clawed to get to this point i don't see
the harm in you getting a new car at
this point since you are millionaires
does she just feel like it's an
exorbitant amount to pay what kind of
car are you looking at
well i would love to get a porsche or a
corvette um but i'll settle for a nissan
pathfinder you'll settle for the
pathfinder what's your household income
um about 200 000. wonderful
and uh what are these cars worth
currently the three of them uh the
pathfinder is about 50 000.
okay
and the other you said you've got three
cars total
yeah we have three drivers soon to have
four
okay
and so once this car goes the transition
transmission dies do you still need
three cars total
it would be nice
okay because you have multiple drivers
in the family
correct all right
well what is our hesitation now that you
guys have three million in assets you
have a paid for house you know where is
your money going currently are you guys
having fun
yeah yeah we travel quite a bit um
i just uh i think she thinks it's
exorbitant
and she'd rather get a used car and i
would this would be my car
so
i've been waiting for a while to get
something like this
well maybe you take her for a test drive
and uh she gets excited about it i don't
know maybe she'll never be excited about
whatever car you choose
but she doesn't have to drive it right
correct okay
well normally we tell people don't ever
buy news a new car unless you have a
million dollar net worth or higher
because you can't take the hit on
depreciating on a depreciating asset
like a car
but you guys can take this hit you make
great money and we also say don't let
your cars add up to anything with a
motor in it add up to more than half of
your annual income
and so i think if you kind of show her
these parameters and go hey we're living
way below our means right now we've
worked really hard to get to this point
now is the time to live like no one else
we lived like no one else so later we
could live like no one else and that is
what it looks like
it's okay to have something nice because
it doesn't have us we're paying cash
we're millionaires this is why we do
what we do
have you explained that to her
i i will try i mean i'm of no use
telling it to you so it's really
you know her better than i do so you've
got to appeal to her senses and go hey
listen i know this feels like a lot and
this is more than we've ever spent on a
vehicle
outside of our home this is probably the
biggest purchase you've ever made right
i'm pretty close are you like an
exorbitant spender all the time are you
buying boats and toys constantly
no no i mean i'm a saver i mean
occasionally if i want to buy something
you know of course after i ask her um
i'll buy it but
we're both savers but she is
over the top savings
well i think she maybe needs to to come
your way a little bit and go hey
we've saved we have plenty we're gonna
be okay
is it a security thing for her where she
goes we need to keep saving this is
unwise to spend this money on a car when
it could go towards xyz
well i i think she's probably worried
that you know maybe if she decides to
quit her job
that uh you know that would bring her
your income to probably
will be
more than half of a hit if she want to
quit are you guys close to retirement
well i'm about
eight to ten years away uh
she could probably work another 20 but
she i think she would like to quit
well it sounds like you'll be able to
with all the assets you guys have built
up
that's that's my contention as well i
think you paint her a picture of what
the future looks like what retirement
looks like and this car becomes
a part of that vision of hey the next 10
years here's what i'm hoping for us what
are you thinking
here's what i want you to retire what
are you thinking and as part of that i
would love to get this for me i've
worked really hard you know we've worked
hard for this family and it's okay for
us to get this car and have nice things
because we're not going into debt for it
we've worked real hard sacrificed to
become baby steps millionaires are you
okay with this and i think if you do it
with that kind of uh you know humility
and intention i think she'll come around
plus the test drive that's what you know
you get her in a test drive i don't know
she may not be a car person
she's she's not a car person she sees it
as utilitarian and goes you're gonna
spend how much is this car gonna cost
you think
uh 50 50 000 okay that feels very
reasonable if you're paying cash you
make 200 grand and you have three
million dollars in assets there are
people who make thirty thousand dollars
who have called in buying a fifty
thousand 000 car and financing the whole
thing
yeah so nothing about your situation
feels frivolous or crazy so you're on
the right path uh it's just i don't know
how that conversation is going to go
with her
but showing her the numbers and showing
her what a plan looks like for the
future giving her that security that
this is not going to throw off your
retirement plan doing this i think that
might be helpful for you thank you so
much for the call
all right folks here's some sad news for
you half of americans over 65 will need
long-term care and the average cost of
that care is
138 000
so you've got to plan for your long-term
care needs now and i talk to people all
the time whose quote plan is to let
medicare pay for it i've got news for
you though medicare won't pay for
everything that's why we recommend
long-term care insurance for people aged
60 and over it helps pay for nursing
home care assisted living and in-home
care costs like medical equipment help
getting dressed and eating and home
modifications so you can get around
safely in your home
that way you get to keep your
independence and your savings long-term
care insurance protects your family too
your spouse and kids won't have to bear
the financial and emotional burden of
caring for you and since you're not
using all your savings on long-term care
you'll be able to enjoy your retirement
years with your family and leave a
legacy that provides for them after
you're gone we've got a network of
endorsed local providers that will help
you understand your long-term care
insurance options and find the right
policy for you that's why they're ramsay
trusted because they'll put you first no
matter what so if you're 60 or over it's
time to connect with a trusted elp and
get your free long-term care insurance
quotes just go to ramseysolutions.com
long-term care to get started that's
ramsay solutions.com
long-term care
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five
five two two five
donny joins us up next in st louis
donnie welcome to the show
hi george hey appreciate everything you
guys do um
my uh question is i'm gonna be debt free
in july awesome and i will have my
emergency fund fully funded
september of next year
and at that point i'll be saving up for
a house but the problem is i'll be 47
with no retirement
so i'm trying to figure out what's the
max amount of time i need to give myself
to say it for the house before i you
know bite the bullet and start
contributing to retirement before it's
too late so you have zero in retirement
currently
yeah and you're renting and you said
you'll be debt-free in july but the
emergency fund won't be funded until
next september 2023
yeah
why is it taking so long
um i've been doing six months worth of
expenses for the emergency fund and also
saving for
uh
15 000 for a vehicle in case because i
don't ever have a car payment again
either
so 15 for emergency fund 15 for a
vehicle what's your income
about 73. all right is that household
income are you single
yeah okay
so you're making 73 you got nothing in
retirement you want to get a house which
i want you to be a homeowner eventually
and you're looking at you won't start
saving for this house or investing for
retirement until september 2023 at this
rate
yes
i think we need to do better than that
that's just too far away for me to be
comfortable with
so the question is what can we do able
to save up uh 24.40 a month
that's how much you can save up per
month
yeah okay it's just doing 40 hours
that's without overtime so that's worst
case scenario because i like to prepare
for worse and hope for the best but yeah
i mean the next if you want to do this
and do it right the next few years are
going to be tough and you're going to be
working overtime for a while
until we're in this house and we're in a
good place where we're investing 15
so i think you need to have a plan for
both i don't want you just investing and
never get into a house
because i want you to have a fixed
expense i mean you've seen how rent
increases have been going lately
and over the next 10 20 years when you
think about how rent's going to increase
um i want you to have a fixed expense
there and eventually have a paid for
house from retirement
yeah
my worry is is that if i did if i saved
at 24.40 a month and saved that for a
200 000 house that would put me at july
of 2030.
that's not okay the problem is with
houses going up now you know you heard a
hundred thousand more than that now than
more a couple years ago
yeah my worry is seven years from now
and i'd have that saved up
for seven years after emergency funds
funded you know where they're gonna be
at
well you know i would do my best to
speed up this process of getting to a
fully funded emergency fund and maybe
you go three months
is your job pretty stable
yes
so what if you split the difference and
you went three or four months in the
emergency fund
and then you got after 15 of your
household income going to retirement and
then saving up the down payment with any
money that's left over
how long would it take you then to save
up let's say 10 of a reasonable
house in your area maybe it's a condo
well i want to do at least 20
and um to get rid of the pmi
sure
um right now at your age where you're at
original
my original plan was to save up cash for
our house originally
so they'd love to do because i'd love to
never have debt again
but
original plans are out the window now
we've got to look at what the future
looks like for donnie at 47 who doesn't
want to work till he's 70. i assume
and so i'm looking at what do we do in
the next 15 years to set you up for
success so that you can retire with
dignity
have money in the bank and be in a home
and so that might look like we're not
paying cash we're not able to put 20
down but we can put 10 down and
eventually we'll get rid of that pmi
once we have enough equity it's not
going to be there forever so i don't
like that but i also don't want you
saving up for a house for eight years
right that's not a good plan either
yeah i'll let you guys say like three to
five years sometimes yeah my goal for
you is how do we get how do we get into
a house in the next three years while
saving 15 for retirement
and then i want to i want you to reverse
engineer it and go okay what kind of
income would i need to have in order to
do that what do my expenses and budget
need to look like in order to do that
okay
so that's what i'm doing if i'm in your
shoes are you doing a budget currently
yes okay
i'm gonna give to you ramsey plus to
help you along this journey that
includes every dollar premium our
budgeting tool and financial peace
university i think you need a little
fire under your belly to get you on this
plan and do it much faster because an
eight year plan
i'm i'm depressed thinking about it
that's just too long yeah
i mean you're gonna be in your late 50s
finally getting a lot of money
over time but yeah
so
let's find out what you can do to get
that 73 to 83 to 93 to create that
margin and let's see what expenses we
can cut and go bare bones and go i want
to be in this house in three years i
want to be investing a year from now
and then you'll have some breathing room
and in 15 years worst case you'll have a
paid for house if you do a 15-year fixed
rate mortgage which puts you at what 62
now you're not going to be in the house
for a few years so let's call it 65.
you're 65. now you've got a paid for
house you've been investing for
16 17 years at that point
so now you have a good chunk of change
in there and you've reduced your
expenses because you don't have a
mortgage payment anymore
right
so i would make that your vision for
that kind of freedom later on in life
but it's going to be a slog to get there
for the next few years but i would have
a plan for both i don't want you just
investing and not focus on the house i
don't want you just focus on the house
and not investing so i want you to get
investing as soon as possible and do
whatever you can to get this debt
rid of fast get that emergency fund in
place and uh get at it man
rooting for you may joins us up next in
austin texas may welcome to the show
hey george thanks for having me
absolutely how can i help
so i am about three weeks away from
paying off my debt but i
yeah but the timing coincides somewhat
unexpectedly with needing to buy a car
so my question is given the used car
market and my general unfamiliarity with
it i'm not sure what i can get with the
amount or what to set aside from like
waiting to pay off my debt and i was
looking for some guidance on how much i
should spend on a car
okay what's your income
uh 55k
all right and you're three weeks away
from being completely debt free and how
much money do you have in the bank
uh just my thousand dollar emergency
fund right now okay
so once you get this debt out of your
life in a few weeks then we can focus on
stacking up some money for the car
and i obviously we've got to get that
fully funded emergency fund in place but
this car sounds urgent
yeah
what's driving the urgency you don't
have a car at all right now
yeah i've been borrowing a car and
they're gonna need it back ah
and you're using this car to get to work
i assume yeah
okay
is there public transportation options
in your area
no i commute pretty far okay
it's a far commute well let's get you in
a car asap for your your income i mean
obviously we need to get a car right now
it's not going to be the car
so let's let's paint a picture in our
mind of what this car is it's going to
be nothing fancy i probably would look
at spending
five thousand dollars in today's economy
that would be considered a beater uh so
that's what i would start looking at i
would probably jump on autotrader and
all these different sites and see what
kind of car i'd be looking at and i
would go for um you know a camry and a
cord a civic
something in that of that nature that's
going to be reliable for you that can be
high mileage and still get you from a to
b safely
all right and i don't care what the
color is the more rusted the better um
because that that'll give you more
buying power to get a deal so make sure
you don't get hosed on fees don't pay
anything other than a small doc fee and
sales tax if they're trying to push you
into warranties and other kinds of fees
walk away run away
and you could look on facebook
marketplace that could be a good way to
go with a private sale they'll be better
at negotiating on that end so that might
be an option for you too but right now
i'd go into research mode as you pay off
this debt and figure out what kind of
car we're saving up for and then stack
cash as fast as you can
can you get a side job can you do some
side hustles in the meantime
um i yeah i just signed up to do to
teach summer school so awesome that'll
be coming let's go hey this is temporary
sacrifice for long-term gains you'll get
there congrats on debt freedom hope to
get you in a car soon and get you on the
path to building wealth that's the goal
thank you so much for the call this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsey personality george campbell
taking your calls today to help you with
your life and your money the number is
triple 825-5225
colin joins us up next in oklahoma city
colin welcome to the show
how you doing george great how are you
i'm doing pretty good i can't complain
too bad so i had a few questions
for you i recently just graduated
college two weeks ago actually congrats
i just started my first full-time job
nice
so obviously with that i've seen a
significant increase in my interim and i
do have school student loan debt and i
wanted to know from you from your
perspective going from a college student
that obviously wasn't making that much
money to having a significant increase
in money how should i budget that to
where i can pay off my student loans as
quickly as possible well the short
answer is you're going to keep living
like a college student until we get rid
of this debt
so that's not the fun answer
the fun answer is you have a job two
weeks out of college man that's amazing
yes sir how much are you making
uh i just started out with 33k a year
and my student loans are 18k
and my problem is that i've never really
budgeted and uh i know that's obviously
an issue like i went through last month
and added up everything and i spent 502
in food last month whenever i feel like
i could be down because that's eating
out a lot and stuff 100
i did the same thing when i first
started budgeting i was like i'm a small
man and i'm spending 700 on food every
month where is this going so i love that
you're paying attention to this stuff
especially your age how old are you
i'm 22. actually just turned 22
yesterday awesome well happy birthday
that's fantastic
so when it comes to budgeting with this
newly found income
the easiest way to do it is every dollar
so you can go download that app i'm
happy to gift you one year of ramsay
plus which includes the premium version
of every dollar so you can connect it to
your bank it'll track your transactions
and then you can drag them into the
right categories so here's how you want
to make your budget you're going to
first list out your income so you
probably get two paychecks a month
something like that yes sir
so with those paychecks we're going to
put the income at the top and then i
want your income minus all of your
expenses to equal zero meaning we've
given every single dollar coming in a
job
no unemployed dollars
so when you do that you list out all of
your expenses for the month and this
will take maybe you know three months to
get the hang of and get it dialed in
you're obviously going to have your
basic expenses your food utility shelter
transportation are you renting right now
i'm actually not i'm still living at
home with my parents but we're looking
to move out with me and my girlfriend in
september
okay
well
you don't have many expenses right now
so i would use that to your advantage
while you're living at home to pay off
these student loans as fast as possible
do you have any other type of debt
i honestly don't nothing besides the 18k
student loans okay
so your take-home pay i assume is going
to be closer to 24 25 000 a year after
taxes
yes sir somewhere around there and is
this a 40 hour a week job
yes sir okay
i would also look into some kind of side
hustle something you can do on top of
that or overtime to increase your income
even if it's temporary to get rid of
this 18 000.
now i don't know what you can do in
oklahoma city to do that i'm sure
there's lots of options so i'd get
creative find something that you can do
that's at least 20 bucks an hour in
today's market
to knock out these student loans
so when you make that budget obviously i
want you to be tracking it not just make
it once you make it you got actually
track it and before you make any
purchase look at the budget and go what
does my budget say i can do
that's going to be your permission to
spend
alrighty that's my problem is i honestly
have a problem saying that one of the
strengths want to go and eat so
well i think we need to set up some
boundaries with friends and go hey i
want to hang out with you guys can we
hang your place tonight do we have to go
out can we get some pizzas you know find
ways where you can trim down or you go
hey guys i'm trying to pay off this debt
this is my this is a huge goal for me
i'd love your support in that and that
might mean i can't go out as much or i
go out and get a soda water
and i eat before i go out
i understand and they may think you're
not cool but i'm not really concerned
with that i'm more concerned about your
financial future and you winning with
money
and that's hard to do at your age
especially with with friends so that's
what i would be doing man i'd get on on
top of this thing
and i don't love the idea of of
girlfriend moving in with you it gets
real messy real quick so i'd encourage
you to find another way to live
separately for now until you guys you
know are in a more committed
relationship moving towards marriage so
that's my hot take but i'm gonna gift
you ramsay plus uh a birthday gift
partially and a graduation gift so it's
a two-fourth special here austin's gonna
pick up we'll gift that to you and get
plugged in with every dollar premium get
plugged in with the financial peace
university videos and you'll be on your
way man to getting rid of the student
loan debt
elizabeth joins us up next in dc
elizabeth welcome to the show
thank you so much george for having me
absolutely honored to take your call how
can i help
well i i guess i needed a little
encouragement um kind of a push to spend
some of this
money that we've saved up that's a fun
problem to have
yeah right i know as i'm saying it
i'm uh it is a good problem um
so my husband and i are debt free and we
just sold our house in washington we're
gonna be moving um so we find ourselves
needing a second car where we're gonna
be moving
and i really i'm having trouble
pulling the trigger on spending some of
this
money we got from the sale of our house
on purchasing a car
we're looking at around between 40 and
fifty thousand dollars to
buy this second car and i just
i really don't like the idea of
sending this what i view as kind of the
house fund for purchasing our next house
on buying a car so you feel like this
this money kind of has a name on it
already in its future down payment
exactly how much uh profits are we
talking from this house sale
uh it was 200 000. so netting 200 000
what's your household income
it's about 300 000.
what do you guys do for a living
uh lawyers
lawyers okay fantastic and you're
debt-free debt-free lawyers we're
debt-free we're debt-free lawyers that
is rare we're anomaly yes it is rare
yeah we don't talk about it as a mixed
company for sure that's amazing yeah
they get upset so you have a fully
funded emergency fund
you have a fully funded emergency fund
yet and you're investing 15 into
retirement
yep and we're doing kids college as well
we have two kids rock stars okay this is
a good problem to have what is the other
car worth
the other car is a 10 year old prius so
uh i don't know maybe
it's got about 90 000 miles maybe 10
thousand dollars okay so this is the
nicest car you've ever owned as lawyers
uh we have never
owned the prius was the night a
five-year-old prius we bought was so
this feels frivolous because you're like
fifty thousand dollars
okay yeah it's very very frivolous i
think that there's no problem in you
buying a fifty thousand dollar car with
your income being debt-free being where
you're at in the baby steps it's more of
the emotional side of oh my gosh i want
to throw up thinking about spending this
much money while knowing we want to get
into another house eventually so are you
guys renting in your new city
yes we'll be renting and
we can spend the next year saving up
you know to replenish the house fund
that's my thinking i would set a very
specific goal for how much you want to
save up
how long that's going to take when you
want to get into this house how much
down
down payment you want to throw in there
and that way you don't feel bad because
you have a plan it doesn't feel
spontaneous and frivolous you go no the
plan is to spend
40 000 on a car leaving us 160. we're
going to pile on another 100 in the next
year giving us 260 to put as a down
payment
and now you go okay none of this feels
frivolous and if you do that with a
15-year fixed rate mortgage with at
least 20 percent down which you guys
should easily be able to do with your
income and timeline and have that
payment be no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay which making 300
grand you've got some margin there
yes right yeah i think the lack of a
plan is probably what's making it feel
frivolous yes it's really just kind of
in my head rather than down on paper and
so i think once you put it on paper and
you look at the numbers you go oh this
isn't ridiculous at all this is a small
piece of our world of our net worth of
our income that we're throwing to this
car and you know what we've worked
really hard
we're not financing a 50 000 car to
impress people we're doing it because we
want it and we don't care what anyone
thinks about it and so that's what i
would be doing get with your husband go
on a date night and start to make a plan
for what your next move looks like to
purchase this house and as long as
you're following those steps
you go get you that car i'm excited for
you guys way to go this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day
james 4 3
when you ask you do not receive because
you ask with wrong motives that you may
spend what you get on pleasures
william arthur ward once said
opportunities are like sunrises if you
wait too long
you miss them
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two five five two two five i'm george
camel your host this hour chris joins us
up next in los angeles chris welcome to
the ramsay show
hi george hey thanks for having me yeah
absolutely what's going on
uh yeah so the short of it is um i just
graduated medical school i'm 28 years
old um and i uh luckily i'm not carrying
any debts
anymore and
let's go yeah thanks
thank you appreciate that um but yeah so
my i'm about to start residency training
in july and my family as a graduation
gift essentially is giving me 40 40 000
um just to kind of get my uh get me
started um so i can you know hit the
ground running and i have about ten
thousand dollars my own money saved uh
and i'm just calling just to see um you
know what your opinion what your opinion
is on what i can do with it to kind of
maximize you know my savings or my
investments and retirements you know
anything like that um because i've been
in school for forever and i
don't really um i'm kind of new to this
whole um finance thing that's awesome
man thanks for joining our crazy crew
here so let me recap here you just
graduated med school completely debt
free and you have ten thousand dollars
saved in the bank
yes you are a unicorn my friend how did
you get through med school debt free no
wrong answers
uh so it's a combination of a bunch of
scholarships um and family help
awesome
fantastic news man
so you got 40k here and you're going
what is my next goal how much are you
making in residency
i'll be making uh 57 000 uh pre-tax uh
which i calculate out to be around 40k
take-home per year oh i love how nerdy
you are this makes me happy
okay so you got 40 000 take home and you
have forty thousand that'll be a lump
sum that you can do whatever you want
with what is your next goal for chris
are you going to be renting somewhere
yes uh so i will be renting um so i'm
moving to a new city so i i'm renting
for now
not really thinking about buying a house
that's my current salary i guess sure
yeah you don't need to rush into that do
you have a car do you need a car
i will need a car um because my car
will be staying here with my family um
and i'm going to need to use some of
that 40 000 to
help purchase a car
so what i would do i think you your next
step would be a fully funded emergency
fund you don't quite know your expenses
yet but i imagine it's gonna be a little
more than ten thousand dollars for three
to six months of expenses
actually so um funny enough is that for
the last uh four years in med school my
um i've actually been
tracking my expenses uh as you mentioned
i'm very nerdy so i literally have like
a spreadsheet going with all of my um
all my you know expenses and everything
and i actually tried to kind of get a
better idea of how i budgeted out and i
actually spend about or with rent and
everything and rented food and
everything my monthly expense is around
um 24 to 2700 per month awesome now
you're gonna have a new rent that'll
come into play right
that's actually i that's 24 to 2700 is
actually including the new rent that i'm
i just signed a lease for okay so that
adds up to about 16 grand so let's call
it 15 grand as a fully funded emergency
fund for you does that sound good
yeah yeah so let's take five of the 40
you're getting and add it to your
savings that becomes your emergency fund
we're not touching that unless it's an
actual emergency urgent necessary
unexpected
so the rest of the 35 sounds like you
need a car
yeah so let's get a reasonable used car
we don't need anything fancy here and if
i'm you i'm probably not spending you
know more than 15 grand
to do that does that sound reasonable
actually yeah that's perfect i've
actually been looking at used cars i'm
looking at around like you know 10 to 15
is kind of what i'm what i'm looking to
spend on the car wonderful so that then
leaves you with an with 20 grand left
and i want you investing 15 of your
income your future income into
retirement so i'm guessing residency you
have a retirement option there 401k
something like that
yes i believe my my hospital is gonna
match four percent i think is what i
read awesome so i would invest fifteen
percent if they've got good options
there if there's a roth 401k option i'm
an even bigger fan of that that'll use
after tax dollars it'll grow tax-free so
invest 15 of your income that's outside
of the match they're gonna match four
percent you still invest 15 of your
income there and with that 20 000
sitting there in savings i think your
next goal would be to keep stacking up
money and so that eventually you'll have
a nice big down payment to put down on
your first house
okay
okay so
uh
5k added to my 10k as in virtually fine
correct um around 15 nothing more than
fifteen thousand for uh a nice used car
um fifteen percent of my
uh going like moving forward income into
the 401k raw 401k if i can yep um
uh and then the rest of it just kind of
hold on to and kind of keep building it
up until i can put a nice down payment
do you nail that man i love dude you're
already my best friend today
i want you to be my doctor
this is the kind of guy you want in this
profession
that's awesome man your family really
sets you up so well i'm proud of your
you
your sharp young dude and your family it
definitely left a legacy
thank you i appreciate that um i guess
one more question first question on that
would be like so um in terms of kind of
just keeping the money in as like a
savings uh so would you not would you
recommend or not like kind of taking
some of that money and starting to
invest it into like you know mutual
funds or etfs or anything like that
if you want if this is a longer time
horizon you're going hey i know for sure
i'm not getting in a house in the next
three to five years i'm okay with you
parking that in index funds mutual funds
to grow
while you save up
but at this rate and how long are you in
residency for
three years okay so i think it'd be it'd
be a cool goal personally to go hey at
the end of residency what if i had
enough to put down on a house with my
newly found income that you'll have
which i assume is going to be high six
figures
right yeah
so i love this plan maybe you wait a
year once you have that new income
you'll be able to stack up a lot of
money really fast so in four years
you uh you put that money down on a
house so maybe you could put 40 50 down
who knows
right okay
i love this man i'm proud of you dude
i'm gonna send you a copy of my favorite
book that changed my life the total
money makeover hang on austin's gonna
pick up and we will send you a copy of
that to encourage you along the journey
grace joins us up next in portland grace
welcome to the show
hi george how are you i'm doing great
how you doing
but i'm getting well
i i guess i'll i'll set the scene for
you set the stage
sounds good so my my husband and i um
bought a fixer-upper about six months
ago and we're moving out of state um
into the house
um so we've been doing a full renovation
on it and it became clear a few months
ago that it was costing us
a lot more than we thought it would
essentially murphy's law happened um to
us
but that's okay
um we're debt-free besides the house and
in order to stay that way
um a few months ago we decided to
pause our retirement investments so that
we could continue to cash flow this and
make the house livable so we can get out
of an apartment and go ahead and move in
um
we were really comfortable with that
decision because we knew it was a
temporary decision and it should be the
renovation should be done in about a
month
um but with all this talk of the stock
market being down
and knowing that this is kind of
cleaning us out so we'll have to rebuild
our emergency fund
to make it fully funded my question is
when do we start investing again
do we do it immediately as soon as the
renovation's over so that we can um
get back in the market oh sorry uh 25
okay so you got plenty of time on your
side but i want you to get back to
investing asap i don't see why you can't
get the emergency fund filled back up
then immediately get to investing 15
and any extra money you have left over
goes towards the renovation and if it
costs if it's gonna take longer because
that i'm okay with that and if you go
hey we got to call it quits on this
renovation because it's not even going
to roi
we're not going to see this appreciation
in our sales price because we put 50
grand in and the house price didn't go
up 50 grand
so
we we do have to
finish it to make it livable because we
don't have anywhere else to live okay
and
but but you're good with us keeping a
pause on the investments until we
rebuild ourselves just get the emergency
fund built back up and don't let this
renovation hold you back from doing that
i'd rather you pause the renovation and
get an emergency fund and be investing
that's my goal for you i'm good with a
slower pace on the renaults that puts
this hour of the ramsey show in the
books my thanks to all the folks in the
booth to you america we'll be back with
you in the meantime remember spend
wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you